hi I'm Kathy Calvin and I'm the CEO of
the United Nations Foundation we were
founded 12 years ago by Ted Turner who
believed that everyone can help the UN
be a stronger institution and help take
care of the world and right now we need
your help to help haiti the devastation
there the loss the number of orphans the
hunger and the rebuilding that has to
take place is enormous the UN is in
place to do the job and has been already
making a national and international
appeal for help and funds we've been
gratified by the number of people who
have stepped up with ten dollar
contributions to ten thousand dollar
contributions and we need everyone's
help you can go to the UN foundation's
website wwu UN foundation org and find
out how to text to give or send the
donation or some simply give support to
the UN for the work it's doing the next
big challenge is going to be
reconstruction and all the nations of
the world need to help get in there to
rebuild schools and let the markets
flourishes get people back to work so
please how payday we're all part of the
same world thank you